richard ratcliffe the husband of nazanin
zagar ratcliff is today starting the
19th day
of his hunger strike he's calling on the
government to do more to bring his wife
home
from uh iran
let's talk to the former foreign
secretary now chair of the health and
social committee and that is jeremy hunt
of course mr hunt thanks for joining us
on the programme this morning we chatted
to him richard earlier on in the week
and he was not in good shape when is
this going to be resolved
well i saw him yesterday and first thing
to say is he is an incredibly brave man
and he's brave for two reasons firstly
because he is doing everything possible
to get nasanim released but secondly
because he's the first person in this
situation and there have been many over
the years who's gone public about it and
so the world knows about iran's hostage
taking and i hope one of the things that
comes out of this
is that
iran and other countries that are
thinking of doing this in the future are
shamed into not doing so because it is
an outrageous thing in the 21st century
that countries actually take innocent
people hostage in order to get their way
on diplomatic issues
why when you were foreign secretary did
you not organize for this 400 million
quids worth of debt that we owe the
iranians to be sorted out and then she
could come home
well that is the heart of the issue and
i did make a lot of efforts uh in that
direction i went to tehran
to
meet the then foreign minister to try
and understand what was blocking her
release um and i think we have moved on
now
when i was foreign secretary there was a
debate about the principle of it
and we established that this is not
paying ransom money if it was paying
rats money i wouldn't support paying it
this is paying a debt that an
international court has said we owe
the defense secretary has said we owe
and i think there is now no argument
about the principle of it is difficult
iran is a is a horrible regime that does
the most despicable things so it doesn't
make anyone comfortable doing it but now
it's about the mechanics they are
sanctioned it's not totally easy it is
doable and we've just got to get on and
do it
so we should pay them
we should absolutely pay them because
this is a debt and we are a country that
pays its debts and even if
it is a totally unsavory regime we
should pay this debt there should be no
linkage whatsoever between this and the
case of by the way not just nazanin but
anushia shuri murad tabaz both wonderful
people both innocent both people who
have got incredibly supportive and very
very distressed families and you know
this is definitely an impediment in the
relationship
and whether or not iran sees there to be
a linkage we need to solve this issue
anyway and we should get on and do it
i think there's a meeting today isn't
there with the iranian deputy um fm what
should come from that
well this is actually really good news
it's encouraging uh this deputy foreign
minister is over here because of cop26
and
and i think that
what uh the reason that we're encouraged
about this is that when i was foreign
secretary we always asked ourselves
whether it was a waste of time talking
to the foreign ministry because the
government in iran was really controlled
by the hardliners the revolutionary
guards who reported to the supreme
leader
but now the hardliners have actually
taken over the government so ironically
it might be more productive talking to
the foreign ministry because they might
be speaking to the whole of the
government including the people who are
holding in hostage
um you were also health secretary you've
had lots of titles as part of this
government
and you're now chair of the health and
social care committee where are you
where are you as far as uh double jabbed
um staff uh no longer being able to work
from today in care homes
i think it's a very difficult issue um
the practical issue is you know what is
going to be the impact of some people
leaving as they undoubtedly do but i do
support it because in the end if your
mum or your dad is in a care home or
indeed in a hospital i think you have a
right to know that everyone taking care
of him or her
has taken trouble to make sure they're
not spreading a disease asymptomatically
it is the first responsibility of every
doctor nurse or carer and every single
one that i know has been jabbed twice so
i think it is the right thing to do it
will keep patients safer but i do
recognize there are some practical
challenges
of course you can still pass on kovid
even if you have been double jabbed even
if you've also had your booster is daily
testing not a better option
yes but you know daily testing is not
foolproof either um the one thing you
can do that you know will make a big
difference is to get jabbed and i think
that uh people working in health and
care do understand that and they want to
put the
safety and the protection of the
vulnerable people that they have after
all
given their lives to looking after they
want to put that first so
look it's a really difficult issue it's
difficult in the care sector it's
difficult in the nhs but i do think
sajid javed is right to have bitten the
bullet on it
you're a senior member of the party the
government how embarrassing is it for
our prime minister to be standing up on
the world stage and saying we are not a
corrupt country
well um
you know i'm not a member of the
government but i am a conservative mp
i'm proud to be a conservative mp and
all i would say to
anyone who is laughing at britain uh
laughing at our democracy anywhere in
the world is it is because people like
you are asking people like me these kind
of difficult questions we have one of
the most active
vibrant toughest media scrutineer
politicians anywhere in the world that
we are actually less corrupt than most
countries and that's not to say we're
perfect that's not to say we get
everything right but the fact is we are
a very open robust democracy and i think
ultimately that is actually to our
credit
with that in mind you were there during
the expenses scandal how similar is this
i think it's one of those things where
um
one or two elements of wrongdoing may
cause the rules to be changed um and i
think
there are some gray areas where there
needs to be more clarity
we know that you're not allowed to do
private business from parliamentary
premises
does that apply if someone calls you on
your mobile for example and you happen
to be in your office in parliament and i
think uh
what this will do is mean those kind of
rules are clarified and that's a good
thing
and is it okay to do your business um as
an mp from the british virgin islands
well i don't want to talk about that
individual case k um because that's
going to be investigating choose any
place you want let's say majorca is it
okay to work for several weeks away from
parliament
well there are lots of lovely corners of
the world where you know we would um we
would all love to do our work from but
you know i think in this particular case
we we just need to let the investigation
happen and find out whether the rules
were broken
good to talk to you as always mr hunt
thank you
thank you